[Music]
ikea
is renting out tiny tokyo apartments for
under one dollar a month
ikea
ikea are they furnishing these
apartments for people to come and see
the they are furnishing them so swedish
furniture company ikea's offering a tiny
home apartment in tokyo for the price of
less than a dollar a month for one year
ikea said the 107 square foot apartment
in shinjuku district will be rented out
on one year lease for a price of 86
cents per month not including utilities
what's the square footage you said 107.
whoa so we're talking tiny 107 it's not
bad still like a 10 by 10.
that's one way to look at it yeah i mean
bro if you've got a roof over your head
for one for one dollar a month obviously
yeah
that's not bad yeah and you can live in
tokyo that's pretty sick yeah you just
go there to sleep i said shinjuku's like
well i think that's like party city a
lot of optimism here i like it yeah
we all have asian mentality that's why
we're all like we're like yeah it's all
good it's a good deal you know what i
see the resources that's actually
cheaper than a capsule hotel yeah
it's bigger yeah because capsule hotels
are like 20 bucks a night i like tour
bus beds dude i don't hate it you do
what you got to do yes i'll rent four of
them for four dollars make one my living
room one of them my bedroom one in my
kitchen you did it bro bart's just gonna
break the wall you know what i'm gonna
do
i'll rent the whole building for 36
dollars yeah
man just goes to one guy he's like come
on man don't be a dad that's not what
we're trying to do
applications from prospective tenants
who must be at least 20 years old we
should all do it let's do it let's just
do it as a group let's just all apply
why wouldn't we all of us for one room
no we each apply for one room and then
we knock down the walls and then you
sublease
at a premium price and then for two
dollars oh and then we could we could
lease it to a youtuber for like a
hundred thousand dollars a month yeah
a hundred thousand x gains
think about what we could do
that's good it's good so the apartment
is being furnished with ikea products
it's all good to me one of the keys is
to make good use of the vertical space
the company said on its website by
capturing the room three-dimensionally
new possibility possibilities open up in
limited space you know what's funny is
if you just rent it
take chuck out all the furniture put
pier one and creighton barrel stuff in
there
but the room only has just one it cost
you a million
i'm like hey can we can we upgrade to
restoration hardware on this
one yeah you fancy
a little rh in there
yo bro i'm not i'm on tv bro i love it
yeah
it's that patel money
you know my new bag is for furniture
it's so [ __ ] expensive i haven't
afforded one thing but it's okay i like
looking at it yeah soho home
what's that i gotta check it out it's so
you know soho house yeah yeah they have
soho home which is their furnishing
sector wow and if you are a soho house
member you get discounts but if you're
not then it's just ridiculously
expensive that's the like a price of a
coffee table or a couch or something
probably four grand
yeah that's more than rh we're about to
say yeah it's [ __ ] expensive but
they're sick as [ __ ] because if you've
been to tell the house everything's just
like bougie and nice and weirdly like
cool yeah right yeah because you're
paying for it you are paying for it yeah
you are paying for a subscription ikea
is promoting this tiny home with a
series of videos featuring a person in a
shark costume portraying a real estate
agent videos feature the shark named
blog are they in the apartment
they take
that is such a japanese marketing tactic
his name is blahaj
b-l-a-h-a-j does that even have to do
with anything you got a suit on bro no
seriously can we do this what's the
shark
like why wouldn't i is that the room
that's the room that looks kind of cool
dude i'd go to japan and live there for
a month for one dollar
i've never been yeah then i don't spend
any money on logic and it's safe as hell
too so oh i'd [ __ ] love it dude
it's supposed to be like their
kind of like dodgy area but it's like
well that's why it's what's dodgy dodgy
for them
it's like beverly hills first
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh you said that you said there's
brothels and [ __ ]
are they one dollar also yeah he's like
wow
yo ikea sponsored brothels for a dollar
well you only get the mouth or the hat
but but it's still a shark
if it's a shark you got a shot i'm
intrigued
i'm intrigued
their bad area is still like our good
area so it's it's kind of hard that area
is our fantasy yeah yeah that's true
it's a utopia as long as criminals stay
in jail they're a bad area is what our
politicians campaigned for
we'll be like the bad parts of japan
i'm voting for this guy
what yeah what are the major problems
going on in japan right now from like a
civilian point of view isn't it like uh
nobody's having kids
yeah i mean like
underpopulated
too much stress from their parents yeah
clean cars
the economy hasn't recovered since the
80s but it's still the top threes still
this is working on fukushima fukushima
they're like guys our sushi reputation
was really ruined by fukushima we got to
bring it back but everybody's still
eating these radioactive fish that's
okay yo you know that movie uh dreams of
uh europe yeah i hear people say that
sushi's not even that good who said that
for her my mom i told her about it you
should stop yeah because you should stop
value by baby
stop buy one get one feed promos on
postmates
do you guys remember sushi boy that fast
food chain yeah i remember sushi boy it
was just now okay it was like your mom
said uh the girl places yeah when that
documentary came out i was like oh have
you seen jira you know she goes oh yeah
that old guy
and i'm like
apparently by the time the documentary
came out on netflix i mean was it
netflix yeah yeah and the world got it
yeah it's been out for a while for them
it's already old
and then
so the the hot spot was actually zero
suns
so they're like because out there
they're like why would you want old [ __ ]
so like we want the traditional real
[ __ ] right like everyone outside of
japan old ass fish but my mom over there
like
i want the cutting edge new school [ __ ]
i don't want this old [ __ ]
grill
girl yeah i want a philadelphia roll
what the [ __ ] she's like more cream
cheese more cream cheese eel sauce sad
bro
bust out the blowtorch
because remember we were gonna do it we
were uh remember we're gonna do a trip
out there and i was like oh maybe we
could get um you know like like we could
get a booking so i was trying to tell
her about that i was like oh you want to
go mom like we would go get a [ __ ]
booking i thought she'll be like excited
and she goes that old place she's like i
raised you wrong oh like what what do
you mean
[ __ ] up and she goes ah that fool
doesn't change he's stubborn you gotta
get some new stuff i'll take you to a
place with french fries on me
that's what i want baby i want a four
michelin star that's where they just
deep fry everything
four michelin stars baby everything's
deep fries that's a lot of hot now
yeah when i went to japan i think the
only thing it wasn't about like who or
what uh like or what restaurant you went
to in the city it was just about going
to the tsukiji fish market at like 6 a.m
which i missed out on it's like as long
as you go there and i remember waking up
butt crack at like 4 a.m early trying to
get to the [ __ ] sushi spot you walk
through the market everybody's killing
these giant tunas and [ __ ] like that and
then any [ __ ] of the small-ass spots
that have long lines that are right next
to the market you just gotta wait in
that line for like an hour and then once
you get in they're hurting you get like
20 minutes to eat you don't get to pick
what you eat they're just like you sit
down a small spot they [ __ ] give you
what they give you the second they
finish giving you to give you the check
tell your ass to get out i went to the
market and then i went i saw i witnessed
a fruit auction and i saw a cantaloupe
sold for three hundred dollars just one
what you know the place that you guys
went to they moved it
so so that chance like i missed out on
the the that fish market that that was
there for like a hell of a long time
it's now it's i mean it's not the fish
market i mean the locations change so
they move the whole thing is are those
guys mafia iran because a lot of dudes
are tatted the [ __ ] up like driving the
fish truck system i mean yakuza yeah i
was like oh sure i'm like these japanese
guys look different
refer to them in the right offices
in japan
a lot of bronx transplants in tokyo
anybody want to use guys better buy it
can i go [ __ ] you'll pass me the
tuna
it's not the wrong tuna i want a
mozzarella on my tuna
that's like kind of kind of seattle fish
market maybe at best where they throw
them where they throw the food yeah
yakuza in seattle for sure everywhere
dude
joe might be yakuza we don't know no
all right well now we know where are we
there's your chance to admit it take his
word for it you know i like the whole
like tiny living and like tiny homes van
life uh miniature [ __ ] it's like a weird
uh minimalist society
nowadays right subculture i feel like i
remember hearing about that kind of
stuff out of like uh necessity upwards
building and vertical like it used to be
called homelessness yeah yeah and yeah
living out of your car because you're
down and out whereas now in america it's
like a trend imagine how people in hong
kong feel about that [ __ ] that they're
seeing people in places that are huge
america's like look at this tiny home i
built with all this land that i have and
everybody in hong kong is just like what
the [ __ ] this is like the best we got
you know what i mean yeah they're pissed
they're watching hgtv saying [ __ ]
that's all they do
you really want to depress yourself just
drop like a random pin on zillow in the
middle of the united states oh my god
and you're like
what the [ __ ] i can own a 19 bedroom
house on 82 acres with 48 cows for like
half a million dollars
or they're giving it away i can get one
tire in los angeles
like i can get one tire for my car for
the same price
it's not even real estate it's not even
real estate it's wheel estate yeah it's
like everybody that lives in montana
we'll give you a parking spot we'll give
you one parking spot
i have a buddy that lives in montana and
he was uh recording this i was watching
stories and he goes like oh cool look at
the deer drinking from my creek
i'm like what the [ __ ] dude time to go
[ __ ] himself we got a homeless man
drinking from the sewer
dude i'm getting emails every other
weekend about like homeless people
fighting outside of my apartment
building i'm like what the hell is going
on it's a comment dude it sucks a
homeless guy took a brick from my house
and threw another homeless guy who stole
his bike in front of my house no yeah
did you hit the brick back nope i
literally don't know where it is and it
was a cinder block did you at least take
the bike no he took it and he ran off he
ran he took a bike and he ran instead of
ran off with it and the guy was chasing
him it was crazy crazy but if you have a
dope house in the meta verse doesn't
matter that's true
there's no metabolism homeless people in
the metaverse though just to keep things
sleeping
how'd you get in here
well because we live in los angeles it's
cheaper for me to buy vr than to buy my
own
they just gave it to him i decided to
just join the metaverse
it's
squatting on your nft land
[Music]
you